imagine that we have a hierarchy of
conception
such that some things we perceive and
conceive of are shallow and other things
are deep and the Deep things are those
upon which many ideas are are dependent
the deeper down you go the more it
becomes religious in some real sense and
so there's no getting away from the
religious if you think about it
technically in that manner and then if
you don't have a religious story or a
religious substrate then it seems to me
that what happens is the political
starts to become the substitute for that
depth Dennis Prager has a very nice
formula he says big God small government
big government small God what you have
in some ways is the ferocity
of the Reformation uh you have the the
kind of attitude which was captured in a
man for all seasons where the
son-in-laws ask you know would you knock
down a law to get the devil and he says
well of course and he said and then
would you knock down the next law and
then when you finally end up uh having
driven the devil all the way to Wales
and he turns what is going to stand
between you and him now that you've
knocked down all the laws all of this is
is a is a modern religion and I think
has to be dealt with you know that
that's why I'm working on this paper on
the Democratic parties two wings as
weird and insane the weird Wing is sort
of in touch with reality but weird uh
the insane Wing is totally out of touch
with the real world and is drifting off
into a Never Never Land in which it is
quite prepared to kill people like you
and me if that's the cost of getting to
Nirvana
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I have the great
privilege today of speaking with one of
the most remarkable political figures in
the U.S in the last four decades five
decades perhaps Dr Newton Gingrich
speaker Newt Gingrich is Chairman of
Gingrich 360. a multimedia production
and consulting company based in
Arlington Virginia
as former Speaker of the House of
Representatives Gingrich is well known
as the architect of the contract with
America that led the Republican party to
victory in 1994 creating the first
conservative majority in the house in 40
years
he was also a republican candidate for
president in 2012.
Gingrich is a Fox News contributor
podcast host newt's world and syndicated
columnist he is the author of 41 books
including 18 fiction and non-fiction New
York Times bestsellers his latest books
include Beyond Biden rebuilding the
America we love and Trump and the
American future solving the great
problems of our time
Gingrich and his wife Ambassador kalista
Gingrich host and produce historical and
public policy documentaries recent films
include the first American and divine
mercy the canonization of John Paul II
recognized internationally as an expert
on world history military issues and
international Affairs Newt Gingrich is
the longest serving teacher of the joint
War fighting course for major generals
he also teaches officers from all six
Services as a distinguished visiting
scholar and professor at the National
Defense University
in addition
Dr Gingrich served as member of the
defense policy board he was a member of
the terrorism task force for the Council
on Foreign Relations and he co-chaired
the task force on United Nations reform
a bipartisan Congressional effort to
modernize and improve
the United Nations
the gingriches reside in McLean Virginia
and have two daughters and two
grandchildren I thought maybe we'd start
by talking about
your your contract with America which
was a a major political initiative back
in the 1990s mid 1990s I think it
originated in a speech that Ronald
Reagan gave in I believe 1985. I've been
working with a variety of people
recently on formulating something
approximating a Manifesto of
conservative values and that was
something that you did essentially at a
more political level with the contract
with America and so could you tell me a
bit about why you did that what your
motivation was how that worked and and
what and what came what what occurred as
a consequence well sure first of all if
you are
trying to be the party of change
uh it's very helpful and I think almost
essential that you outline a formula
uh for change there's something Margaret
Thatcher did beginning in 1975 and which
I had studied a great deal and I worked
with Reagan starting in 1974 and in 1980
we had the first capital steps event the
first contract uh and Reagan outlined
five Big Ideas and it led to uh and we
had all of our candidates standing on
the capitol steps and it led to a
surprising series of victories in the
U.S Senate we took control when nobody
thought we would so I had that
background of having already done that
I believed and I still believe and I
think will be true this year that uh
when you are the party seeking change
you have to nationalize the election
uh there has to be a common theme a
common argument because you have to
build a wave of support bigger than
individual candidates can create
and so in 94
we really were working off of that
framework in the two books I always
recommend to people are Claire
berlinski's there is no alternative why
Margaret Thatcher matters and Tom Evans
book the education of Ronald Reagan his
years of General Electric and if you
read those two books you could almost
see how the contract emerged
it is true as one of Reagan's
biographers said that about 70 percent
of the contract can be found in the 1985
Reagan State of the Union but that's
because Reagan had begun articulating
the need for profound change as early as
his speech for Goldwater his national
televised speech in 1964 which is still
available on YouTube called a time for
choosing and is a remarkable speech and
then when he ran for governor in 1962
five he began running and he ran with
welfare reform as one of his first
topics so this uh the concept of for
example being for welfare reform had a
long gestation uh and had been uh
dramatically accelerated by a book that
Charles Murray wrote called losing
ground which proved pretty conclusively
that government inspired dependency is
very destructive and particularly
destructive for people who are poor
um
so that was the background we had a
couple of very simple principles
no issue was involved there wasn't above
70 percent approval and the reason there
is if you're a conservative in virtually
every country in the world the media
will be opposed to you and so you have
to have issues that are so powerful that
after they got done lying about it
you're still above 50 percent so you
can't afford to wage a campaign on a 55
issue because by the time the media is
done lying about it you'll be down at
40. but if you have a 70 or 80 issue
they can't lie enough to make the issue
unacceptable so we consciously put those
together the other thing we did that was
probably unusual and people I think
didn't fully appreciate its time we did
not pick up two of the issues I
personally believe in right to life and
school prayer because we knew that the
New York Times And The Washington Post
and others would use those issues to uh
demagogue about the contract and to make
it impossible to ever get to the other
issues
um we then had to get all of our members
to agree to it and the one person the
one politician at least who understood
what I was doing uh was Chuck Schumer
the Democratic leader of the Senate who
wrote a book in 2007 and devoted a
chapter to the contract and said
correctly that the greatest purpose of
the contract was not just to win the
election
but it was to radically change the house
Republican party that by getting them
committed to these really big changes
and to a timetable of voting on all of
it in the first hundred days I
guaranteed that the first majority in 40
years would be by Washington standards a
radical majority
uh and if we simply won elections
without the contract uh the lobbyists
and the interest groups would have
absorbed most of our members and we
would have been as useless as most
congresses are so uh there was a lot of
conscious thought about what we were
going to do both in terms of values and
in terms of actually being able to
implement it and he also understood uh
the Reagan principle that if you could
get a 70 or 80 percent issue and you had
the nerve to stay with it that
ultimately the president would have to
side with you and that's what happened I
mean Bill Clinton signed bill after Bill
after Bill that nor normally no liberal
Democrat would have signed but because
he wanted to get reelected he got in the
habit of working with us even though it
infuriated liberal Democrats and the
result was we got welfare reform on the
largest capital gains tax cut in history
Food and Drug Administration reform
telecommunications reform meta of care
reform in an election year which was
amazing and ultimately we produced four
consecutive balanced budgets the only
four balanced budgets consecutive uh in
our in my lifetime
what were the main platforms that that
emerged out of the contract for America
the idea that we wanted to move people
from dependency to work we wanted to
change the nature of the welfare system
so that it's when you went to a welfare
office instead of having a clerk who
tried to maximize your dependency we
turned them into employment offices we
were deeply affected by a firm called
America Works which uh interestingly
Mario Cuomo the Democratic governor of
New York had helped create and it was a
very effective entrepreneurial
work-oriented system still exists
designed to take the hardcore unemployed
and train them into being able to hold
down a job uh so so we I would say
welfare reform is Far and Away our
biggest success the second one was uh in
a sense ironically uh we we've
campaigned on a constitutional amendment
to uh require a balanced budget we got
300 and I think six votes in the house
which was enough for a constitutional
reform we fell one vote short in the
Senate so it didn't pass
but we realized if you had 306 votes in
favor of a balanced budget and if you
had 66 votes in favor of a balanced
budget in the Senate
you could pretend that you had passed it
and just go ahead and pass a balanced
budget and so that decision which was
entirely uh
uh an act of will in the part of the
house Republican leadership led to a
project which within four years had
balanced the federal budget when almost
no one thought it was possible uh we
also had very strong Provisions about
applying to the Congress every law which
applies to small business we had a
provision for you know the how this is
really ironic the house in its entire
history for over 200 years had never had
an audit
uh they spent money every year a member
spent money every year and when they had
no capacity to be audited and so part of
what we committed to was creating an
annual order which still exists to this
day
um the tax cut we could we campaigned on
which included uh eliminating any
capital gains tax on your home as long
as you reinvested the money in another
home
um and which had the largest cut in the
actual capital gains tax in American
history uh was just extraordinary in
launching a a generation of economic
growth and finally we had very strong
provisions on deregulation because we
felt that the government bureaucracies
were killing our economic growth and the
result was we had literally I think a
decade of entrepreneurial and small
business activity that would not have
occurred without the contract and
without the Republican majority
the midterms are upon us and it's time
for some real change inflation isn't
going away and if the current
Administration keeps handing out free
checks Americans won't just be hurting
they'll be fighting to survive the
typical Investment Portfolio of 60 40
stocks and bonds is down by 34 percent
it's worst drop of the century millions
of Americans are taking a hit what can
we do to set things right you could
invest in assets that aren't dragged
down by the stock market like fine art
with Masterworks Fine Art Is So
disconnected from stocks that even as
the 60 40 portfolio keeps losing Fine
Art is selling for 26 more than it was
last year just recently Mass work sold a
painting for a 21.5 net return to their
investors go to masterworks.com and use
promo code jbp to sign up for
Masterworks and skip their waitlist
that's masterworks.com promo code jbp or
click the link in the description see
important disclosures at masterworks.com
CD
[Music]
so what do you think the consequences
were of the welfare reform Provisions
that you that you introduced well I mean
we know from studies that getting people
in the habit of going to work getting
them into their first job having them
learn that it's okay to get up on Monday
and go do something
um having them begin to realize that if
they worked hard they could actually get
a better job so if you see it as a
emotion picture and not a snapshot it
isn't just the first job that the first
job leads to a second job and a third
job and I think the net there's no
question the net result was because
there have been lots of studies the net
result was millions of people who left
dependency got a job uh the largest
number of children taken out of poverty
because the incomes of their families
went up uh in American history and it
was wildly successful but it went
straight against the left which hated
the idea of having a work ethic and
getting people out of dependency I mean
there there was just this almost rabid
feeling uh one one of the democratic
leaders and then we split the Democrats
50 50 because it was so popular that
half of them voted with us uh to pass it
and Bill Clinton signed it but the ones
who didn't vote for it were from very
liberal districts and you know one of
them basically said you know this was
like the Nazis they're coming for your
children they're going to starve
children I mean the language was
unbelievably hostile and personal and
vicious and it and there's something on
the left
that loves dependency and hates work I
mean it's a very strange phenomenon and
I think probably goes back to uh the
19th century rejection of
industrialization
so you you ran your your your crew ran
four balanced budgets as well and so
let everybody who's listening know what
the consequence of a balanced budget is
and then more importantly what the
consequence of an unbalanced budget is
and what the cumulative consequence is
that especially right now
well actually I've been deeply uh shaped
by studying uh British budget policy in
the 19th century and the recovery from
the scale of debt in the Napoleonic Wars
and the way in which the British worked
very hard to uh lower taxes increase
economic growth and were very frugal uh
Gladstone as prime minister would reuse
all the message boxes uh as a way of
saving money which is partly symbolic
and partly real uh and so I I had I
approached this whole issue of the
budget from the standpoint and I helped
write the our first budget of Hope and
opportunity when I was a freshman in
1979 as an alternative to Democrats and
we were making a couple of arguments one
is that a lower tax system creates a lot
more jobs that those extra jobs create a
lot more revenue for the government
because you have more people at work
earning more money more people getting
profits earning more money
second that the best social policy as
Ronald Reagan said was a job and
therefore having a robust economy was a
major goal and that in the long run you
could have much lower interest rates
and much greater Capital available to be
invested if you had a balanced budget uh
and that we were very anti-inflation and
very much for lower interest rates
because we wanted to have a very robust
private sector that was rapidly creating
new job new technologies new jobs New
Opportunities and if you think back to
that period it was at the very beginning
of the explosion of the internet of cell
phones of a whole range of Technologies
so we were very interested in
accelerating technological change and
that's part of why we emphasized a
dramatic lowering of the capital gains
tax because we wanted to make it easy to
liberate Capital to move to New
companies and New Opportunities and new
ideas ironically when we balance the
budget for four straight years Alan
Greenspan was chairman of the Federal
Reserve and actually reported publicly
in a congressional hearing that they had
a working group trying to figure out
that the projection was in 2009 we would
pay off the federal debt
and they weren't sure how they were
going to technically manage the money
supply if they had no U.S debt uh it was
it was a situation we had not seen since
1837 and they were and nobody predicted
I mean nobody predicted we'd be a
majority in 94. nobody predicted we
could balance the budget in four years
uh and then keep it balanced and it was
it was really interesting uh but but
part of the key to the balanced budget
was it forced you to make choices and it
forced you to modernize the system
so you couldn't afford this you know
when when you're willing to run deficits
everything sloppy becomes acceptable
because after all it's all just money
and nobody cares and so you end up with
huge levels of corruption uh it's an
estimated uh 20 billion dollars in theft
in the California unemployment
compensation last show just by itself uh
you end up with huge volumes of waste
the Pentagon is an embarrassment it is
so bureaucratic and so wasteful uh you
end up with uh all sorts of sloppy
projects because politicians say look uh
since the budget's going to be in
deficit anyway why can't I have my half
billion dollars
and you have no you have no yardstick
there's no there's no way to control the
system and so we wanted to establish a
genuinely controlled government that had
to constantly improve itself uh and uh I
had been a student of both Edwards
Deming uh the father of the quality
movement and Peter Drucker the the best
management writer of the 20th century so
I really brought a very management
intense approach uh to thinking about
the federal government and I wanted the
pressure of the balanced budget to force
us into the kind of reforms we needed
when were the projections being made
that the debt would be paid off by 2009
1999 and 2000.
right right so that was at the end of
the internet boom that was a remarkable
decade in the 1990s of America of
American economics expansion exactly
what we had predicted we said you're
going to get dramatically more growth
that will produce revenue and if you
control spending for example welfare
reform led to such a dramatic drop in
the number of people taking money from
the government
and those people now working and paying
money as taxpayers that you take the
both sides of that equation your the
government's paying out less and it's
getting in more so for almost every
state and almost every state welfare
reform was a huge advantage to their
fiscal budget
so why did the balanced budget vote fail
I know it was only by one vote why were
people opposed to it you you mentioned a
little earlier about uh the Democrat
objection to work I look first of all
there are people who like big government
I mean look look at the Biden
Administration look at Bernie Sanders I
mean they genuinely sincerely like big
government uh second
um there were people who didn't want to
get in a straight jacket they were
thinking oh my God what if we get into a
crisis and now we're constrained well my
view I mean first of all you always have
an escape valve so if you go to war or
if there's a gigantic emergency uh you
can respond to it but as a general
principle in the absence of war and
emergency I think having a balanced
budget requirements good but there were
people who simply wanted to avoid that
kind of control okay so now given that
things worked so well on the economic
and the social front in the 1990s I
lived in the United States during the
1990s and it was it was quite a
remarkable boom period very very
optimistic and and maybe a period unlike
any that has been since particularly now
given the massive success of that
program
Why did Republicans and Democrats alike
relapse in the aftermath
because we went right back to huge
deficits and a growing and and a
spiraling debt
even with that object lesson so why did
people fail to learn and why more
particularly was that also true of
Republican administrations well I look I
don't think either George H.W bush or
George W bush had a clue
about reaganism and about modern
conservatism I think they were just
managers and they managed the system as
it existed I mean when George W bush
announced he was going to work with
Teddy Kennedy on education reform
you knew it was an absurdity maintenance
Kennedy was the chief leader for the
teachers unions there wasn't going to be
any education reform they were just
going to spend a lot more money and
accomplish nothing
and I think that there's a Wing of the
Republican party uh which which is a
managerial wing uh it likes things to be
tidy it doesn't like fights well if
you're going to actually control the
government
it is a struggle because the government
doesn't want to be controlled
so if you're going to actually for
example examine how we managed to build
the F-35 as a bad airplane at such
enormous cost you're going to have every
lobbyist who helped build the plane
petitioning the Congress to avoid the
investigation
uh and so you you end up in a situation
I I once said that that the Future Has
publicist but the past has prison guards
and those prison guards are mostly
lobbyists and they do everything they
can to stop the future I'll give you an
example I've done a lot of stuff I found
at the Center for Health transformation
done a lot of work on health reform
so somebody built a computer model
that could evaluate your eyes
and could we currently have a system
where every year you have to get your
eyes checked if you need for example a
prescription for contact lenses
well the recommendation actually
technically is you ought to get your
eyes examined every other year but of
course if you're an optometrist or an
ophthalmologist you like a provision
that requires annually because that
doubles the income so this company comes
along and actually has figured out you
can you can have a home application
using your laptop or your iPad
and it is literally technically as good
as going in so one year you'd go in and
the other year you'd give it to yourself
in state after state
the optometrist and the ophthalmologist
lobbied to get the state to Outlaw the
new technology
in order to protect their ability now
this is something that Adam Smith wrote
about in 1776 in The Wealth of Nations
that any Gathering of businessmen is a
conspiracy against the consumer
and so all of these interest groups like
a sloppy
uh influence written bureaucratic and
political structure and they don't
particularly want a lean aggressive
competitive environment
yeah you said that okay so you you
talked about this managerial tendency
but also the proclivity let's say to shy
away from a fight the other thing that I
see happening on the conservative front
I would say is that
there the left is capable of offering
young people something approximating
you might call it a utopian vision
and so there's a the psychologist Jean
Piaget talked about a late stage
incognitive cognitive development among
young people was the latest in his
stages in the stages that he laid out in
his stage Theory developmental account
of of of human uh let's say cognitive
progress he called the late adolescent
stage Messianic he believed that that
was a time and it wasn't the case for
all young people but for many where
moving from their group affiliation say
their peer group to full Independence
required something like the
um abiding by a set of universal
principles and so there's a search for
Universal principles that can be
it can be a guideline for life and that
would be part of high-end enculturation
and I think the left has been
particularly good in capitalizing on
that by making the case for example that
if you're concerned about climate change
then you're serving the long-term best
long-term interests of the planet that
you're engaged in some Noble goal that's
outside of yourself and conservatives
have been I would say spectacularly bad
at offering that sort of alternative to
young people a vision and I I think if
you look at what predicts
conservative political belief
temperamentally compared to
liberal or left political belief the
biggest predictor is creativity is the
trait openness and so open people tend
to be more liberal in their political
preoccupations and open people are
actually more Visionary in the technical
sense they're more imaginative and
and then you might combine that with the
fact that conservatives tend to stand
for Traditional Values and it's not that
easy to articulate a vision that's based
on Traditional Values because a vision
tends to be future oriented and so one
of the things that strikes me about your
contract with America and and the work
Reagan did and the work that Thatcher
did was that it was Visionary in some
real sense and then that seemed to
evaporate in the aftermath of that era
and hasn't been replaced by anything on
the conservative side since and I've
spoken to conservatives all over the
world and to Centrist liberals as well
and the degree to which they're starving
for a forward-looking vision can hardly
be overestimated
so
you manage this and what what made your
era different and and the people that
you worked with and why were you able to
um communicate it in a manner that was
effective enough to have it adopted by
such a wide swath of people you know
um
without being presumptuous
you could make an argument
that the three most disruptive
Republicans of modern times
uh were Reagan Trump and me
uh and that all three of us are outside
the norm
for the Republican Party
uh the Republican the Republican Party
Norm uh is to raise a lot of money
hire really good staff
hope somebody near you is thinking
uh and actually
almost deride
uh the idea
of visionary language and all that
fancify stuff uh this is this is a this
this is by the way in enormous problem
in the American Military
there was a point there was a point
around 2004 or five where John Petraeus
called me from Iraq
and he said I really had to get to know
a guy named noggle and AGL who was at
that time an Army Major and who had
written a brilliant book called eating
soup with a knife which is actually a
phrase from Lawrence of Arabia who said
that fighting a guerrilla war is like
eating soup with a knife it's very very
difficult
so I read naugle's book I called noggle
and talked to him and the book is a
scathing
on ending uh
example of the Army's absolute inability
to think in Vietnam
I mean it's just astonishing how bad the
US Army's thought processes were in
Vietnam
and I called Nago and I said hasn't this
really hurt your career and he said no
nobody in the Army reads aha well you
know I did some work with the U.S Naval
Academy in in Maryland and uh we were
looking at personality factors that
predict military ranking and to some
degree academic success and it was
pretty clear from that investigation
that General cognitive ability was a
predictor like it is for most activities
that are complex but the next most
powerful predictor and this isn't that
surprising was trait conscientiousness
and that's basically orderliness and
industriousness
certainly openness which is the
creativity Dimension predicted not at
all now it also doesn't predict standard
university grades by the way you were
talking a little bit earlier about the
managerial proclivity of the run of the
mill Republican and also about the fact
that you and Trump and Reagan were all
Outsiders
it's it seems to me that in
manager managed bureaucracies
that openness is a detriment to progress
from the bottom up is when you're in the
bottom ranks what really predicts your
success is conscientiousness dutifulness
the ability to run out an algorithm
that's already pre-established and if
you're open and creative at the bottom
rungs of an organization like that all
you're going to do is cause trouble now
the problem with that is that as people
progress through the ranks all the
people who are creative get winnowed out
they might be absolutely vital
at the highest levels of organizations
but their tremendous amount of trouble
at the bottom and so and that combined
with that intrinsic skepticism that you
described
um among the let's say run-of-the-mill
republican
um acolytes
means that vision and ideas are in very
short supply
it's a very difficult thing to to to
overcome because as I said the Visionary
types I mean this is this great moment
in the 19th century where
um
the
peel decides
that he cannot refute the argument of
the people who want to change the Corn
Laws and allow the price of corn to drop
dramatically to feed the industrial
working class and he uh in the middle of
the debate he turns to his deputy and
says you have to answer this I can't I
think they're right peel then splits
the conservative party because the
conservative party base is farmers who
are growing wheat who which was what
they meant by corn who really wanted
these tariffs to protect their price
so peel takes with him all of the great
bright members of the conservative
government uh and and this is why
Gladstone ends up as a liberal
the only person left
who is articulate
is a half Jew
who had been considered a fop which was
a term of derision who had worn velvet
coats had toured Europe with his
mistress and her husband and had written
novels
now in the absence of Peel
splitting the conservative party
this really would never have emerged
and yet he was the only articulate
person on the floor of the House of
Commons who could defend the
conservatives
and as a result all of these wheat
farmers who would normally have
disdained him
decided he was their leader
now you only need a handful of
Visionaries we didn't need seven Reagans
you know one Reagan was enough the
tragedy was Reagan picked a managerial
personality from the anti-reagan wing of
the party to be vice president
and that's how you end up with George
H.W bush who never understood reaganism
promptly broke his word about raising
taxes and had no notion of the degree to
which Reagan had fused together social
conservatives and economic conservatives
and nationalist anti-soviet
conservatives
uh then when Bush leaves and frankly am
I standing up to Bush on tax increases
was a key moment in creating The
credibility that led to the success of
94 because I proved to the average
Republican Grassroots person there was
somebody there who actually cared enough
to fight
and we actually had more votes in the
house Republican conference than bushed
it uh and at that point you would the
dye was cast for the future uh but in
the process I ultimately infuriated the
bush wing of the party
uh and as soon as they could get away
from what I had and basically what I was
doing was reaganism
so as soon as they could get away from
what I was doing they reverted to the
norm
an enormous frankly a pretty dull
managerial party uh that this doesn't
have any sense of what you know uh H.L
Menken once wrote of the Harding
Administration that it was like an army
of ants crossing the desert which When
It Came Upon an idea wondered what it
was and trampled it to death trying to
study it and then resumed its march
across the desert well that does that
described a large wing of the Republican
party now the difference is on the left
you have lots of vision and fanaticism
but they tend to be out of touch with
reality I I tell people the reason the
left can't deal with violence whether
it's criminals terrorists or Russia is
that they saw The Lion King movie and
thought it was a documentary and they
think that lions and zebras actually
sing and dance together and we cannot
convince them that lions eat zebras so
while they have a vision it's in it's
insane I'm actually working on a paper
that there are two wings of the modern
democratic party a weird wing and an
insane wing
yeah yeah well I I mean that that does
seem to be
um that that Paradox that you just
described with the Visionary Democrats
who are out of touch with reality and
the managerial uh Republicans who are
out of touch with vision does seem to be
a logical consequence of the of what
would you say the excessive control that
people at different temperamental
extremes might have of both parties
because the stereotypical personality
who's going to lean to the left
on the pathological side is someone
who's extraordinarily Visionary but
completely impractical and then on the
right you're going to have someone who's
so practical that they can't shift
Direction when it's necessary
and I would say those are the those are
stable States in some sense on both
sides and you talked about Outsiders
like like Reagan and and yourself and
and you put Trump in that category too
those are people who come along I
suppose now and then and shake up the
Republican party why would you put Trump
in the same
categorical domain in that sense as as
Reagan and yourself because you had
actually a pretty coherent vision uh he
really did want to make America great
again he really did believe in a a
pretty sophisticated America First
foreign policy uh he was really prepared
to take on the bureaucracies and shake
them up I mean the part of what defines
uh the the entire uh process with Donald
Trump is that the establishment whether
it's the bureaucracy uh or it's the news
media uh or it's the the FBI or it's the
billionaire Elites to New York they all
understood that he was their mortal
enemy that uh that if they didn't go
after him every single day and every
single way
that he would destroy their world
uh and that's what he was doing I mean
there's no question in my mind he was
Waging War on a corrupt establishment uh
and the establishment was fighting back
I mean I think he was the most
disruptive person since Andrew Jackson
in terms of actually taking the
establishment head on
uh and being prepared to uh violate all
of its norms and I guess I'm curious too
I haven't been able to figure out for a
very long time why conservatives have
been unable to be attractive to
minorities especially immigrants because
by and large immigrants to Canada and
the US are much more conservative than
the population itself and so why do you
think the Republicans have been
historically unable to make the
connection with minority voters is it
the policy on immigration do you think
or the uh the notion that they're a
status quo party
well I think first of all that the uh
historically they were the status quo
party and I think that immigrants are
basically told you're supposed to be a
liberal Democrat uh what's happened is
uh as liberal Democrat has turned into
radical Democrat uh they've said that's
not me
uh and I think that you're seeing this
has been a gradual steady drift in the
right direction uh and I think you're
seeing uh I think Bush actually got up
to 44 percent of the Latino vote in
2004. uh and uh then we backslid for a
little while and now we're back again uh
and I I suspect that this year uh and uh
in 2024 uh we'll actually carry a
majority of Latinos and from the
standpoint of the Democrats that's the
beginning of the end uh if they lose if
they lose working class whites and they
lose Latinos they can't be competitive
it's so interesting to see too isn't it
that as the Democrats beat the
oppression drama and claim to be
standing up for the victimized in this
remarkably moral manner that they're in
fact alienating exactly the people that
they claim to support first of all the
working class because they did a
cataclysmic job of alienating the
working class especially especially in
the Clinton campaign it was something
stunning to watch and now exactly the
same thing is happening on the minority
front and so the very people whose whose
Tender Mercies are supposed to be being
targeted by this victimization narrative
are the people who as soon as they
understand it do everything they
possibly can to reject it but but I
think that's happening in part because
among the
uh graduate school educated Elites
you're you're really dealing with a
secular religion uh rather than a
political movement and therefore you
have all of the
um fervor and intensity and blindness of
a religious movement uh so uh they have
to assume that these other people are
just wrong uh they they can't hear them
because this the message is being sent
to them uh by minorities and by working
class whites are messages which are
heresy given their secular religion uh
and I think that that's you know that's
at the heart of this that's that's why
you kind of something like Bill Gates
say recently that it's really good we
have these really high prices uh for for
fossil fuels because that's really going
to lead people uh to understand how
important greenism is well you know if
you're a family that that's going to
have an electric blackout this winter or
you're somebody who can't afford to buy
heating oil you somehow think a
billionaire telling you how good it is
for you to be in pain it's probably
pretty stupid yeah well you know the
Deputy Prime Minister in Canada Christia
Freeland said exactly the same thing
about high gas prices in Canada at the
pump it's like it's good for people to
pay a little bit more when they're
filling up their car because it helps
them understand just how serious the
climate crisis is now you describe this
as a secular religious movement
um on the left what do you think the
elements of that secular religious
movement are and I'm going to put
another codisil on that question too you
know so there's famous gospel dictum
obviously that you render are unto
Caesar what is Caesar's and unto God
what is gods and one question that
arises as a consequence of that is that
is what happens if you don't Render unto
God what is God's and it looks to me
like what happens is that the sacred
collapses into the political
such that the political becomes sacred
for those who are a religious
it's inevitable and I was I mean I'm
sorry I've been thinking about this from
a psychological perspective you know so
if you think about
if you imagine that we have a hierarchy
of conception
such that some things we perceive and
conceive of are shallow and other things
are deep and the Deep things are those
upon which many ideas are are dependent
so constitutional axioms for example in
that manner would be deep and this
self-evident presuppositions upon which
the Constitutional axioms are predicated
would even be deeper
the deeper down you go the more it
becomes religious in some real sense
and there's no getting away from depth
in that manner because without that
hierarchy of depth you have a kind of
incoherence at best and so there's no
getting away from the religious if you
think about it technically in that
manner and then if you don't have a
religious story or a religious substrate
then it seems to me that what happens is
the political starts to become the
substitute for that depth and then we
get into a situation where we can't even
talk about political things anymore
because it becomes taboo and that seems
to be part of this secularized religion
that's part of what it's part of woke
activism it's part of the insistence
that human beings are a cancer on the
planet and destroying it it's part of
this this insane insistence on climate
remediation before everything else
including providing food and shelter and
energy to the poor
and that seems to be what's being
rejected on Moss by the by the working
class and also now increasingly by
minority voters
regular has a very nice formula he says
big God small government big government
small God
uh and in a way when I described oh yes
I haven't heard him yeah when I
described big government socialism uh in
my most recent book I was trying to get
at this notion
um
what you have in some ways is the
ferocity
of the Reformation
uh you have the the kind of attitude
which was captured in a man for all
seasons where uh you where the
son-in-laws ask you know would you knock
down a law to get the devil and he says
well of course and he said and then
would you knock down the next law and
then when you finally end up uh having
driven the devil all the way to Wales
and he turns what is going to stand
between you and him now that you've
knocked down all the laws and I think
what you have on the left is a is a the
ferocity of the Reformation the ferocity
of the French Revolution at its peak
Calista and I visited uh the cemetery in
Paris where the Marquis De Lafayette is
buried uh and uh it was a cemetery uh he
personally was not harmed by the
revolution but his wife's relatives were
all Aristocrats and they were all
guillotined and they were buried in that
cemetery and so she asked that he and
she be buried there it's also the
cemetery in which the Catholic nuns
uh were buried who had gone singing
to the guillotine because they refused
to give up Christ and they were
therefore had to be guilted
um it's the ferocity of leninism uh
which annihilated much of the social
structure of Zara's Russia it's the
ferocity of maoism which annihilated
much of the structure the Confucian
structure of China well that ferocity uh
is what leads people to say that we
ought to have transgenderism for
three-year-olds we ought to make sure
that we have a black dormitories in the
name of anti-racism that we ought to
make sure that white males don't get
hired for anything because they're
they're clearly the source of all of our
problems that we ought to condemn
Christopher Columbus for having
discovered the new world uh because
somehow he eliminated the purity of
Native Americans which requires a
stunningly a historical understanding of
Native Americans
um all of this is is a is a modern
religion and I think has to be dealt
with you know that that's why I'm
working on this paper on the Democratic
party's two wings as weird and insane
the weird Wing is sort of in touch with
reality but weird uh the insane Wing is
totally out of touch with the real world
and is drifting off into a never-never
land uh in which it is quite prepared to
kill people like you and me if that's
the cost of getting to Nirvana yeah well
this is the thing that that strikes me I
was just in Europe for several months
touring through the UK and and and
through Holland and and Finland and
Germany and Jerusalem all sorts of
places
um it was very interesting to be in
Berlin because of course the Germans as
well as as the people in the UK it looks
like they're going to be in for an
unbelievably harsh winter in their
estimates in the UK that up to 40
percent of small businesses now face the
risk of bankruptcy and even the guardian
that horrible left-wing reg published a
an article about two two weeks ago which
was actually a pretty good article
things considered pointing out that
because of the climate of the UK that if
people aren't able to heat their houses
up to a reasonable temperature which
might be the temperature that drives out
damp that the houses start to develop
black mold of course black mold destroys
houses
structurally but worse than that it
produces Airborne toxins that damage the
respiratory systems of particularly of
children and so the guardian pointed out
that one of the unintended consequences
let's say of the energy crisis is that
perhaps millions of of British children
are going to develop permanent
respiratory problems as well as
compromising the structural Integrity of
a good chunk of the U.S or of the UK
real estate market and all of that
Insanity on the energy front appears to
me to be driven and the conservatives
are responsible for this in large part
by these appallingly uh moralistic say
Net Zero policies that have as one of
their immediate
consequences the
um the impoverishment of those who are
already struggling and so it looks to me
that the left is perfectly willing to
sacrifice the poor
which are hypothetically the people that
they are standing for in order to well
let's say to not save the planet we're
going to get the best they're going to
get the worst of Both Worlds say we're
going to throw a couple of billion
people into poverty including a bunch of
people in Europe we're going to make the
environmental crisis such as it is much
much worse
and we're going to make the
environmental crisis much much worse by
doing so and so this is this is this is
a stunning set of Affairs as far as I'm
concerned and I can't understand for
example why people like Boris Johnson in
the UK marched so forthrightly into the
maw with these idiot Net Zero policies
with no evidence whatsoever that the
crisis that they were designed to
prohibit or to to forestall actually
existed and at the expense of
conservative principles and at the
expense of the poor it's like what's
going on in the conservative side there
I mean you know the UK government at the
moment is imploding mostly under the
weight of the aftermath of these crazy
Net Zero policies and the economic Havoc
they're reeking
so why do you think the conservatives
there have abandoned their principles to
such a stunning degree and are following
this crazy left-wing utopian scheme I
think the combination of the Applause of
the media and the Applause of the elites
going to the right cocktail party to be
surrounded by people who packed you on
the back and tell you what a heroic
figure you are uh I always you know I
try to tell people that you can put eggs
in a freezer
and they will get hard
but that doesn't mean they're boiled
eggs
and if I can't get you to understand
that to get a boiled egg you have to put
it in hot water
then I can't deal with you because
you're crazy
that's not an ideological problem it's
an insanity it's a mental health problem
and what you have is a worldwide Elite
sort of the Davos generation of people
who are suffering mental illness
and if you just understand this is this
is a extraordinary it's like the
flagellante in the Middle Ages who went
around from City to City beating
themselves on their back with whips in
order to atone for their sins
uh you know it was a very widespread
movement for a very brief period and
then people realized it was really
stupid
uh what you have now is the the ultimate
catharsis of the insanity for example of
thinking that a teenager from Sweden is
somehow with no real knowledge of
science no real understanding of history
and no real thoughts to consequence
somehow going to be the the fact that
she's now blessed keeping open the
German nuclear power plants and that
that somehow has meaning
tells you how truly sick the system is
yeah well I I've thought for 15 years
that we were living in the in the uh
fantasy of a delusional 13 year old girl
and that was long before Greta thundberg
hit the press and to see world leaders
kowtow to her as if she's an oracle is
something quite stunning to behold
there's something truly archetypal about
that that worship of of something like
oracular feminine innocence it's it's
something like that and it really is it
really is a form of delusional Insanity
so it's always been fascinating to me
you know when Churchill
um goes on the umderman campaign in
1898. he writes a book about the river
War which is a my wife actually got me
an original copy which is one of my real
Treasures
and he Praises Kitchener thinking that
this will lead General Kitchener to be
pleased with Churchill
well kitchener's reaction was who in the
hell is some young lieutenant
to render any judgment on my generalship
he doesn't know enough to render
judgment and even if it's positive
judgment it is stupid for him to have
rendered it now this was a great shock
to Churchill who thought that somehow
writing well of Kitchener would improve
his standing only to discover that in
fact uh Kitchener did not think it was
appropriate for him to render judgment
because he didn't have any judgment as a
lieutenant and and that's my reaction
we've been through two generations
in which parents have thought that
teenagers should like them uh and and
have reshaped their policies there's a
great line
um that uh Dr Ben Carson the first time
I heard him speak uh and he spoke at a
prayer breakfast now he was marvelous uh
he got up as you know he's
African-American uh and he got up and he
started by describing a series of things
about your brain
and he stopped and he said no nobody in
this audience understands anything I
just said
because you have not studied to be a
neurosurgeon
and it's a function of learned knowledge
and then he started talking about how he
got there and he said his mother was a
single mother
and she was Raising he and his brother
and she said to them if you don't both
get A's
Straight A's
the television goes up in the closet
until the next grading period
and he says people will say to him how
how could your mother have done that and
he said well you know she thought she
was the parent
and we went through the two generations
now where the parents thought that they
needed the approval of their children
it's led us to fentanyl it's led us to
uh we have an intern uh at again with
360 who's working on a really
interesting question given that we lost
55 000 people in the Vietnam War over
eight years
and we have a wall that's a little over
500 feet long if you had a wall for the
last decade of drug overdoses next to
the wall for Vietnam how long would it
be it turns out it's about 1.1 miles
that's how many that's how many
Americans we've lost to drugs in a
decade
without anybody having gotten enraged
anybody having said enough of this
anybody having come down for a ruthless
intense anti-drug policy we've lost over
a million people
in a decade so on on the elite side
let's say on the left you're you're
characterizing the typical adherent of
the woke Enterprise on the left as
highly educated in the in the technical
sense
products of higher education on the
liberal arts front or what passes for it
now
and so that is a form of intellectual
privilege and you might say that along
with that privileged position comes a
fair bit of existential guilt which is
something like I have all this privilege
but I really haven't earned it which is
of course the accusation that the
radical left Doles out in no small
amount continually with regard to
Western culture as a whole but you could
say it really does typify the typical
liberal art elite type who's then guilty
for that unearned privilege and is
driven to atone in some real sense and
maybe that's because as far as I can
tell that all that privilege
that is acquired
through what passes for Education isn't
being put to the proper higher order
purpose and so is accompanied by a
tremendous amount of guilt and that's
part of the religious issue here so that
the guilt is looking for expiation
constantly Thomas Wolfe's essay on
radical chic
taking apart a cocktail party at Leonard
Bernstein's Penthouse which was raising
money for the poor in which a wolf
focuses in on the uh Filipina Maids who
are serving the champagne to the rich
people who are there out of no bless
oblige is one of the most devastating
insights and and this of course was
written in the 70s but what you've had
is the emergence of uh the world's first
mass aristocracy
people so well off they don't have to do
anything they don't have to know
anything so what they know is Trivial
shallow and has no relationship to
wisdom uh and they uh in a sense it's
the perfect postmodern world it's a
world in which no fact matters no taste
matters there is no standard and you can
pretend to be something by having read
three totally irrelevant books and seen
five totally irrelevant movies uh and
therefore you're clever uh and
cleverness has replaced wisdom and uh
you of course are superior to all of
these people you know one of the reasons
that the elites dislike Trump so much is
the Trump talks like a blue-collar
worker
uh I I always shall be able to there's a
movie that Mark Wahlberg is in about the
uh guy in Philadelphia who tried out for
the Eagles and ended up being accepted
actually played for three or four years
with the Eagles and if you see the movie
uh the opening scenes are in a South
Florida South Philadelphia Bar
and they talk exactly like Donald Trump
uh and if you are a Yale Princeton
Harvard elitist and and there's a
terrific book by Charlie Murray called
coming apart in which he goes through
and analyzes by ZIP code
and says that people from Elite
universities marry people from Elite
universities and live in ZIP codes with
people from Elite universities and I
used to tell reporters in in 2016. the
reason you don't understand Trump is
that The Apprentice was not on PBS
shortly after Downton Abbey
and therefore you never saw it and you
and you had no idea that this guy had
done television for 13 years
uh and of course to have got to have
actually watched The Apprentice if you
were working for the post of the times
would have been to risk your status uh
because as a snob you couldn't watch
that kind of uh so-called reality TV uh
and I think that's that's a significant
part of where we are uh the the
uh the intellectual left the dominant
wing of the Democratic Party has to
believe in nonsense because it has it's
what it believes in And So It Goes
Around prattling nonsense uh you know
releasing murderers is a good policy
um having uh uh no bail is really clever
uh and then you're shocked to discover
that when you released murderers you
send a signal that being violent's okay
uh and then you find out that the
average person doesn't think it's very
clever to be mugged raped or attacked or
carjacked by people you let back out on
the street
uh and that's part of the Great crisis
of American society today to to say that
uh the entire historic tradition of male
and female the entire Story coming out
of Genesis of God creating man and then
creating women the entire process
biologically which seems to be
relatively common as it relates to human
beings for several hundred thousand or
million years uh is actually phony and
you know and you get to reinvent
yourself
so you have replaced God and instead of
trying to accommodate God's will you
will now reshape yourself and be who you
want to be uh and that will somehow make
you happy even if it makes you miserable
yeah well God's uh
God's self-active self-naming to Moses
in the desert is something approximating
I am that I am or I will be what I will
be and it's very difficult for me not to
see a direct analogy
between that and the claim that identity
is subjectively defined
I am that I am and that something like
the attribution of omniscience and
omnipresence and omnipotence to the
subjective self and it's even worse than
that in some sense because the
subjective self there that's being
elevated which is something like what I
feel I am seems to me to be technically
indistinguishable from whim
so because you could imagine that you
could regard yourself properly in a
selfish sense and by properly I mean
you would regard yourself as an entity
that actually propagates itself across
time and so you're bound by fealty to
yourself not to do spectacularly stupid
things in the present even though they
might feel good if they would compromise
you tomorrow or next week or next month
or next year right you have to view
yourself as an iterating game and this
notion that identity is somehow
subjectively defined and that that
subjectivity can be pinned down to the
moment couldn't possibly be a claim
that's more Preposterous and immature
now I told the senate in Canada when
Canada passed bill c-16 which was the
pronoun law that every idiot country in
the world seems to be jumping on now and
passing that the consequence of
confusing people about the difference
between men and women would be the
production of a psychogenic epidemic
because I knew I knew that young
adolescent girls in particular are prone
to well we've seen like three epidemics
in my lifetime bulimia anorexia and
cutting and it was always adolescent
girls and I think there's psychological
reason for assuming that the distinction
between male and female is the most
basic cognitive category it's the
deepest cognitive category it's the most
profound might be the most sacred in
that sense and that if you throw
uncertainty into that
you imagine that there's a hierarchy of
of psychological instability
and there are people who are barely
clinging to the edge and there's lots of
them just like they cling economically
if you add uncertainty into the
conceptual hierarchy you make marginal
people you drop marginal people into the
realm of insanity and so I felt that for
every one trans child that we
hypothetically saved we'd probably do
them a thousand and that seems to have
played itself out with near perfect
accuracy over the last six years and
there is some unbelievable narcissism
and self-aggrandizement in that
proposition that you can Define your
identity subjectively by whim at any
moment and that everyone else has to
abide by that as if it's
incontrovertible fact well you know I
mean first of all you get you get to
shift Who You Are
uh and that's that whole process of your
definition of three may be different
than your definition at five which may
be different than your definition of
seven but we're supposed to take you
seriously
at this instant if that's who you have
defined yourself as this evening or
today
um secondly I think uh it is it is at
the heart of the Ten Commandments that
you shall have no other God before me
and what we've now said is oh no
you are your own God
uh you are therefore you are therefore
by definition in front of God because
you get to redefine whatever you want to
redefine well once you get into that
kind of relativism
you have everything begin to
disintegrate uh because there's there is
no framework of reference you can cling
to it ironically there are 34 languages
that have different uh declensions based
on sex
so you you have to ask yourself how in
Spanish or French for example are you
going to deal with a relativistic
multi-sex multi-gender environment when
the language in fact
assumes to
yeah well it seems to have something to
do with this disintegration of the
intermediary hierarchy so one of the
things Carl Jung the psychoanalyst said
um back near the end of the second world
war was that
well he said two things that were quite
striking one was that the biggest threat
that was going to confront us in the
future would be something like Mass
psychological instability rather than
let's say uh material want and privation
per se and he also pointed out that the
logical conclusion of the Protestant
Revolution would be that everyone would
become their own church
right that was the degenerative tendency
because of the destruction of
intermediary
um intermediary hierarchical systems one
of the things conservatives can offer
and I think this works out well on the
front of Sanity itself up front of
bolstering Sanity is there is a concept
among
humanistic psychologists in particular
that the atomized self is the center of
the world and that self-actualization is
the
uh is the essence of Sanity but there's
a more
sophisticated version of that I would
say stemming mostly from piageti and
thought that
there isn't any difference between
sanity and proper nesting inside a
hierarchical community so you can
imagine that well if your marriage is
really unhappy you're not going to be
very sane
and if your children are miserable and
misbehaving and your marriage is unhappy
you're even going to be less sane and
that will also be true if your friends
have turned against you and you have no
position in the community with regard to
a job or a career
so it's better to conceptualize identity
and Sanity as the consequence of proper
nesting in a hierarchical social
structure so that you're saying if you
have a marital partner who provides you
with corrective feedback the two of you
have a good marriage and are saying if
you are together jointly back to back in
relationship to your children who are
then stabilized because of your
stability now you're nested inside a
stable family you can walk outside of
that family into the community and you
can Orient yourself properly in
relationship to a job or career and that
also provides you with corrective
feedback from all your compatriots and
your peers and that scales politically
at the level of the city and the state
and the country and so sanity and
identity then becomes the entire
hierarchy of hierarchical relationships
and that's another thing that
conservatives can offer as a vision as
an antidote to this atomized liberalism
that that results in the final analysis
in self-aggrandizement to the point of
of claiming Divine attributes
that's how it looks to me anyways well
that
I think at times you are probably a
deeper thinker than I am I'm only a
politician
so so let's talk about Vision a bit on
the conservative front so we have the
midterms coming up and hypothetically
the house and the Senate are going to
split are going to flip now it isn't
obvious to me that there are Visionaries
working effectively on the conservative
front the Republican front in the U.S
and so what what do you see as the way
forward for the Republican party if it
was if it if it got its act together
let's say and developed something
approximating a vision and do you see
any sources of that Vision emerging yeah
look I think there are a lot of
entrepreneurial personalities who are
each developing different approaches on
different topics different solutions uh
and I think what you'll see is both in
the House and Senate and and among
governorships we have we have a number
of Governors who are actually solving
problems and and developing a general
sense of a productive uh system uh but
but I mean part of the challenge is
I think if you're a conservative you're
trying to create a frame of reference or
a framework within which people are able
to improve their own lives
so we're not we're not trying to set up
uh the the government which then decides
for you what your vision is we're trying
to set up a system or structure in which
you get to pursue the vision you believe
in uh and we believe that that kind of
Freedom uh is in fact really really
important and I think it's interesting
you know I think Lincoln in that sense
may have been the the greatest Visionary
of of American conservatives because
when he described government of the
People by the people and for the people
he's really describing a very open-ended
concept uh he's not describing any one
specific thing he's describing Freedom
uh he he really believed that uh people
had the right to pursue happiness as
explained in our Declaration of
Independence he had done it in his own
life had come out of a relatively real
poverty uh and risen by his own efforts
and his own studies and I think he
thought that the the job of government
was to create a framework within which
people would go and work Lincoln would
be appalled at today's massive number of
people living in dependency so I think
uh the vision that we have to offer is
one that says you know we want everybody
to have an opportunity to get a good
education but and that's a good example
uh Betsy DeVos the former Secretary of
Education under Trump has come up with
this idea of of uh education Freedom
that it's not just school choice but
it's also homeschooling it's also
apprenticeship it is also online
learning that there are many many
different ways that people can learn and
that is not just a 19th century
bureaucracy uh dominated by a teachers
union with uh various credentialing
requirements that are now totally
Obsolete and I think that that kind that
sense that you're going to see a number
of different people in different areas
who are offering specific breakthroughs
towards a more Dynamic a more open a
more entrepreneurial American society
and and frankly a much more
work-oriented American society uh which
is a historically was a key that
emphasis that you lay on work well in in
the lectures that I've been doing
publicly around the world I have placed
a fair amount of emphasis on
responsibility and I think that your
emphasis on work and and my emphasis on
responsibility are likely the same thing
I've been trying to point out to the
people who are listening to my lectures
that most of the meaning that sustains
people through crises in life
is accrued as a consequence of adoption
of responsibility
so if you have good social relations if
you have a good marriage if you have
good relations with your children and
your friends and your and your
colleagues at work you have a good
social Community that's all a
consequence of the sacrifices you make
in relationship to those
um social interactions the amount you
give the amount you put forward the
responsibility that you take for the
Integrity of those relationships and
then when the crisis comes as it will in
your life you'll have that to sustain
you when the going gets hard Hedonism
isn't going to sustain you and your whim
isn't going to sustain you but the
meaning you can derive through the
voluntary shouldering of responsibility
that's always there for you and it seems
to me that that's Akin in some sense to
the emphasis that you lay on on on the
necessity of work does that seem
reasonable actually I think your formula
is pretty close I I would say that
let me the center of my life has been
citizenship at least since uh August of
1958 and that citizenship involves a
sense of
uh responsibility and that
responsibility inherently involves work
uh that you you have if you're
responsible for getting educated as you
know I mean real education requires work
if you are trying to sustain
economically what you're doing that
requires work uh I found in my own life
through several failures that have a
really sustainable relationship requires
work
being close to my two daughters requires
work uh so it's it's it's a sense that
there's there's sort of a two sides of
the same coin if you will is it's not
just work for work's sake but it's work
in order to achieve something that fits
your value system uh and and I like that
a relationship back to responsibility
whether it's responsibility of the
society or to your family or to yourself
or to yourself well yeah so you know the
I don't think that there's any real
difference between the concept of work
and the concept of sacrifice you know I
used to ask my students many of whom
were children of first generation
immigrants what trying to elucidate the
concept of sacrifice I'd say to them
what sacrifices did your parents make so
that you could attend University in
Canada of course they had an instant
answer to that because they knew
perfectly well what their parents had
sacrificed and I don't think there is
any difference between sacrifice and
work and in some sense speaking in
relationship to the biblical tradition
here is that you have to offer up
something that you value in the present
to make peace with the future that
really is the core element of work and
it's the core element of sacrifice right
if if you're just doing what you want if
you're just gratifying every whim it's
not work but it doesn't work out very
well for the future
what work seems to be is something like
the continual sacrifice of at least some
element of the present to ensure
iterable stability across the long term
and so because human beings are
self-conscious creatures and because we
can see the future we have to work we
have to integrate the present with the
future and that does seem to involve
work and that does seem to be the core
element of responsibility and I don't
see how that responsibility can be
shirked without catastrophe if it is
precisely that which defines our are
iterable stability both individually and
socially is something that conservatives
really have to offer young people you
know what and I don't think that the
conservatives generally speaking have
caught on to this is to point out to
young people that the sustaining meaning
in your life will not be found in
hedonistic self-gratification it's a
counterproductive strategy the
sustaining meaning in your life will be
found in the voluntary shouldering of as
much responsibility as possible you know
young people they get that as soon as
you explain it to them they're they
understand they understand immediately
and are vastly relieved to hear it well
it also takes you back to the point you
made earlier which is that people get to
a point where they want a meaning larger
than themselves
and that that's part of this that that
ultimately uh you find a better life by
focusing Beyond yourself not by focusing
inside yourself well in that that inside
yourself is such a peculiar formulation
which I think is why the radicals insist
so much on feeling because when I hear
that as a psychologist I think well what
self do you mean and the rejoinder is
usually well that's self-evidence like
well no actually it's not because if
you're asking acting in your own best
interest All Things Considered you're
not giving way to every momentary whim
all that does is put you in the position
of a dependent two-year-old or a
psychopath and none of that's productive
even if you're abiding by your own true
self in the higher sense then you're
going to make sacrifices of your
momentary whims to your medium to
long-term stability and thriving and
that's exactly what happens when you
mature because two-year-olds have that
proclivity to be governed by whim but
nobody thinks the two-year-old should
rule the world well except maybe
two-year-olds well I think
you know again you get back to some of
the current fads which would suggest to
you the two and three-year-olds can
actually make real decisions uh which I
think is the example of what I meant
about being insane
um and any anybody who thinks that a
three-year-old or a five-year-old is is
prepared to make adult decisions is just
literally living in a world that I have
no relationship to and I can't
understand uh but I think there's also
you know it's it
part of the challenge is that
historically
almost every society I know of is
successful has rights of Passage which
takes you through adolescence into
adulthood sometimes at a pretty early
age sometimes at 12 or 13. but it but
it's but it's made very clear to you uh
that you have been a child and the
children are allowed to do a whole range
of things but that we don't take what
they did as children seriously
uh that there it's not it's not like
you're a small adult you're a child
and then you go through a right uh
whether you are in in almost every
culture I'm aware of this if it's a
healthy culture it has some provision
for you to emerge as an adult
and to and and to now be self-aware that
uh you know that the things you once did
as a child are no longer appropriate one
of the problems of the current system is
that we treat the children as though
they're adults there's no right of
passage and so they end up as 35 year
old members of Congress who are in fact
just big they're just large adolescents
uh they don't have any kind of sense of
maturity or responsibility or any sense
of uh the hierarchy of development uh
and they and they live in a world of now
I mean it's a in a funny kind of way uh
it's it's a it's a remarkably
existential moment where everything is
now
so what are you what are you hoping for
on the leadership front on the
Republican side over the next couple of
years or what do you think is going to
happen are there are there going to be
contenders in relationship to Trump or
is he the presumptive nominee and should
he be
what would you hope for as we move
towards 2024 well I think I
I think that he is
the probable nominee but not the
presumptive nominee
I think that uh Governor DeSantis if he
wants to can challenge him whether
whether DeSantis could beat him I don't
know uh but I think certainly Governor
DeSantis has the capacity uh and and is
doing an astonishing job as governor of
our third largest state
um I think that there are other
candidates who would like to be in that
mix uh and and I I always try to remind
people if you went back to this exact
point
in 2014
um two weeks before the elect the
off-year election
nobody would even have said Trump's name
I mean so so you know and I think people
would have had a sense that Jeb Bush was
probably the front runner so to you know
so so to try to look forward and and I
don't know uh at this point in 2018 that
people would have picked Joe Biden
uh I mean so so in my mind uh an amazing
number of things can happen
between now and the time we actually
pick a nominee uh I mean I mean
certainly Glenn Younkin uh the new
governor of Virginia has shown himself
to be a future star of the party I think
there are other people around who are
serious potential contenders uh we're
going we're about to see Governor Brian
Kemp of Georgia win a surprisingly big
victory
um I also think that there's a whole new
generation coming up of people who are
running around the country and a whole
bunch of senators you know when one of
the ground rules of the U.S Senate is
that every Senator uh Combs the hair of
a future president every morning and
looks in the mirror and thinks why and
thinks why not so you could easily have
six or seven or eight candidates from
the Senate at least starting down the
road
um the uh
so so I would say that Trump is
formidable uh and and probably would be
nominated but he's not certain I think
on the Democratic side uh if this
election goes as badly as I suspect it
will and if Biden continues to Decay and
if Kamala continues to be as utterly
totally incompetent as she is uh I think
you'll clearly see a whole new field of
Democrats and and part of the question
will be if they get beaten badly this
year you know what lesson do they think
they learn I think uh the governor of
California is probably is likely to run
uh Having learned nothing and we'll try
to convince the rest of us that uh
California in which uh San Francisco has
become a disaster uh and uh Los Angeles
has its largest population of homeless
in the country but that somehow
California is a model for the future
even as it loses businesses and and
people who are leaving the state because
they can't stand it anymore so but but
he's got some he has so many resources
that he almost has to run so what what
what do you think that
would be most appropriate for
conservatives on the Visionary side
let's say to be offering to young people
as we move forward with the new house
and the new Senate
Freedom you talked about work freedom
freedom I think I think well because see
Freedom leads to responsibility and work
I just did a seminar with a bunch of
people including Dennis Prager on the
first half of exodus in Miami we're
going to release that November 26th they
and you you mentioned freedom and that's
what that's what made it spring to mind
so when God tells Moses to address the
pharaoh
he tells them uh
to let my people go
and that's a famous line they let my
people go but that's not the line
actually
interestingly enough and it's repeated I
believe it's repeated nine times might
be ten times
just to make sure that the listener gets
it the line is let my people go
so that they may serve me in the
wilderness and what's fascinating about
that is that the vision of Freedom
that's put forward which is the spirit
let's say that's calling
to the Israelites to emerge from their
slavery and to the tyrannical pharaoh to
release his tyrannical grip on them
isn't
the freedom of whim it's the freedom to
pursue the proper goals
to pursue the highest goals and so it's
it's the freedom that comes with the
voluntary adoption of responsibility and
not the freedom that leads to a
nihilistic Hedonism right but but
there's a difference between Liberty and
Liberty
and I think you know I think that the
the challenge is
and this is I think what very difficult
to have a serious public conversation
about it although Dennis Prager does as
good a job as anybody
ultimately the health of the West
requires a profound Revival
I mean ultimately God has to be at the
center of our freedom uh when we say in
our Declaration of Independence that you
are endowed by your creator
with certain unalienable rights if you
don't think there's a creator
then the whole rest of it makes no sense
on the other hand
if you believe that your rights come
from God and your right includes the
right to pursue happiness which in the
sense of the 18th century Enlightenment
actually meant virtue and wisdom
happiness did not mean Hedonism
um then the pursuit I always try to make
two points to people The Pursuit of
Happiness first of all is an active
phrase which gets us back to the work
ethic it doesn't say You're Gonna you
know it doesn't say we'll have happiness
stamps or we need a federal department
of happiness it says you have been
endowed by God with the right to pursue
happiness
and second by that Grant God is also
imposed upon you the obligation that you
should pursue happiness again happiness
in the sense of wisdom and virtue
um and all of that only makes sense if
you understand that you are subordinate
to a Supreme Being it's it's a little
bit like uh Alcoholics Anonymous I had a
good friend who had been very high up in
the Reagan Administration and who was an
alcoholic and ultimately went to
Alcoholics Anonymous found it to be
enormously helpful and uh
ultimately you get to a key step and you
have you have to start by recognizing
you have a problem and recognizing that
you can't solve the problem yourself
but then you get to the key step you
have to recognize that there is a
Supreme Being
a higher power
and so he found himself talking one day
to a federal official and he was
explaining the impact of Alcoholics
Anonymous and this federal official said
you know if we could skip that one step
we could fund it
he said I don't think you understand
that's the step that makes the rest of
it work
and I think in that sense all of us are
caught
in an alcoholic's Anonymous moment all
of us are weakened by the fact that we
don't
live in a culture which makes it normal
and obvious that your freedom is a
freedom within within uh God's belief
and God's control it's not a freedom
against God or a freedom in an atheistic
world
because those are in fact impossible we
might conceptualize Freedom the way we
conceptualize playing a
sophisticated game
every game is ordered according to the
principles of the game the rules of the
game let's say and the rules aren't
exactly walls and they're not
they are not Thou shalt not in some
sense they're enabling principles and I
don't see that there is any freedom
without the rules of a game I think
there's just chaos and Chaos that's
Liberty and freedom let's say that's the
chaos of whim there's nothing about that
that's salutary there's nothing about
that that allows you to maintain
anything approximating sanity it has to
be ordered freedom and maybe that's
something that Visionary conservatives
can offer to young people it's the what
would you call it the attraction of
ordered freedom and maybe we'll see some
more of that happen in the upcoming
years that would be a lovely thing if uh
if the proper Vision can be established
and so I'd like to thank you very much
sir for spending the time talking to you
it's quite an honor you know you've
you've been a name I've known for a very
long time I must say that when I was
young you were definitely not my most
favorite person I was under the sway of
socialist ideas when I was a kid really
yeah yeah yeah and so so uh that during
the Reagan years let's say but um
um it's and it it's quite it's quite a
circumstance to be sitting here talking
to you today and I appreciated it very
much as I mentioned earlier that uh I
really like your work I admire it we
have a number of people in our team at
Gingrich 360 who are huge fans who were
thrilled that we were going to have this
conversation and also I did want to
mention for our viewers that at Gingrich
360 we do have an internship uh for
people who are bright and who are
willing to work hard and so I appreciate
your your I really like what you're
doing and I really think it's important
and a significant contribution thank you
thank you very much if people out there
are young people who are listening are
looking for a signal opportunity then
this internship program looks like that
to me where are you located now we are
in Arlington Virginia and in Naples
Florida
so we have opportunities in both places
okay and are you personally in in the in
the Arlington area I'm in both places
I'm actually talking to you today from
Arlington I see I see well I would love
to meet you the next time I come down to
Washington that would be it would be
good to meet in person and good we'll
I'd like I agree I think I think you are
a remarkable contributor to our time
well thank you sir
um I want to go behind the scenes with
Dr Gingrich for half an hour and so any
of you who are inclined to
um join up with the daily wire plus
platform we'll get access to that and
I'd like to thank you again Dr Gingrich
for taking the time and uh we'll get
this up real soon and and hopefully
we'll be in further touch
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com